bei 7000 jahre alt also 2500 jahre älter
als die pyramiden das ist wirklich mehr
als ein ägyptisches französisches
forschungsteam hat wohl eine der
ältesten siedlung überhaupt im nil delta
entdeckt steinwerkzeuge und keramiken
zeugen davon dass dort schon mindestens
seit dem fünften jahrtausend vor
christus eine langfristige besiedlung
durch menschen stattgefunden haben muss
vorläufer der pharaonen krieg zum
science fiction herzlich willkommen die
älteste siedlung im nildelta wurde jetzt
intel samara entdeckt dass es etwa 140
kilometer von kairo entfernt konkret
fand das archäologie team mehrere gruben
gefüllt mit werkzeugen keramik und
tierknochen dass es wirklich eine
rarität denn das archäologie team geht
davon aus dass diese siedlung etwa 7000
jahre alt ist heißt also dass hier
menschen gelebt haben und zwar bereits
2500 jahre bevor die pyramiden von gizeh
gebaut worden sind die jetzt gefundenen
buben samt inhalt sprechen eindeutig
dafür dass sich die menschen in dieser
region langfristig aufgehalten haben
dazu nadia geht vom ägyptischen
ministerium für altertümer vor allem die
analyse des biologischen materials wird
uns einen besseren überblick über die
besiedlung des nildeltas und die
ursprünge der landwirtschaft gegen
forschungsteams erhoffen sich also durch
diese funde mehr über die ersten bauern
in ägypten zu erfahren wie genau können
wir uns die ursprünge der ägyptischen
landwirtschaft vorstellen und wie waren
die prähistorischen gemeinden
organisiert bevor die pharaonische
geschichte begann gab es dort schon
erste strukturen die auf die spätere
entwicklung des ägyptischen reiches
hinweisen spannende fragen deren
antworten noch offen sind den
forschungsteams wissen bislang nur sehr
wenig über das leben der menschen im
alten ägypten bevor das land durch
pfarrer und regiert wurde beispielsweise
geht die forschung bisher noch davon aus
dass die bauern damals noch keine
bewässerungssysteme hatten und vom
niederschlag abhängig waren ebenfalls
auch vom nil der wohl eine große rolle
beim thema landwirtschaft gespielt hat
denn er sorgte für regelmäßige
überschwemmungen die die sonst eher
karge landschaft in ein fruchtbares
paradies verwandeln
das ägyptische ministerium jedenfalls
plant für demnächst weitere ausgrabungen
in dieser region
dann könnte es sein dass die
forschungsteams vielleicht doch auf
künstliche bewässerungssysteme stoßen
und das wäre eine sensation denn erst
regelmäßige und reiche ernten könnten zu
einem großen bevölkerungswachstum
geführt haben und somit auch für die
entwicklung der ägyptischen hochkultur
das wäre jedenfalls der absolute hammer
frühere ausgrabung sorgt in dem fall
schon einmal für eine überraschung
ebenfalls bezogen auf die vorgänger der
pharaonen denn funde haben gezeigt dass
auch schon die ägypter vor mehr als 5500
jahren ihre toten konserviert haben also
lange vor dem pfarrer und also erste
farbe waren das die hin zur pharaonen
kultur geführt haben wir können also
sehr gespannt sein auf die zukünftigen
entdeckungen hier geht es weiter dafür
draufklicken mysteriöse entdeckung
antike totenstadt in ägypten und wenn er
kein video mehr zu diesem und zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann
folgt mir auf whatsapp nur da bekommt
ihr von mir vor allen anderen
das neueste video ganz unabhängig von
der abo box hier auf youtube die bei
vielen nicht so ganz perfekt
funktioniert ja dafür draufklicken
natürlich auch gerne ein abo da lassen
und genau die glocke nicht vergessen bis
dann bleibt dran